hey guys this video that you're about to
watch is a video that I actually will
teach you how to edit recently I
launched this really cool app that
teaches you how to edit in Final Cut and
this is the video that I edited in the
tutorial in this tutorial I will show
you guys everything how to edit a video
start finish and I even include all the
footage that I used to make this video
so you guys want to check it out I'll
put a link in the description if you
guys enjoyed the app make sure you guys
rate it five stars I'd leave it a really
nice review I will be reading all of
them so thank you guys so much and now
here's the video that you guys can learn
to edit today we're checking out the
insta 360 1x this is one of my favorite
cameras and yes it's a 360 camera so you
can shoot in 360 but you can also do
things like this
[Music]
it's time to unbox I'll show you guys
the camera made all that happen so this
is the camera this comes in several
different versions but this one is the
Apple bundle that you specifically can
get at Apple and what's cool about this
is it comes with pretty much everything
they're gonna need you can buy the
camera just stand alone but this one has
a few extra goodies in it yes here it is
this is everything that comes in this
bundle it's great because it comes with
a camera but it also comes with
invisible selfie stick you can be
filming in 360 and all of the footage
that you're filming the stick is
magically removed and this thing it
actually extends so this long not really
sure how long lettuce this also comes
with two extra batteries and here it is
so this right here is really cool this
is what allows you to get these bullet
time shots this is the bullet time
handle and then you click it onto the
bullet time option and then you just
[Music]
[Applause]
right here this is the button that used
to take pictures and record video and
this is the power button let's see what
else you have in here it seems to be a
protective pouch lovely put your camera
right in there and to protect the lens
so it's cool begins this camera does
connect to Wi-Fi but to connect even
faster to transfer your footage you can
use these cables this USB see and
there's a lightning cable and there's a
microUSB there's another really cool
accessory that this hat is that you can
actually put this camera inside of this
thing that looks like a football and you
put your camera inside of here you
scroll it in just like this and then I
can't make this up you throw it
[Music]
well my favorite things about this
camera is the software that goes along
with it because the camera yes is
incredible but the software is so great
because you can take all of the footage
that you shoot import it into your phone
and then edit it right on the fly this
is something that I previously edited
while I was in Hawaii this is the little
tiny planet mode that you can do you can
zoom in and this gives you a really
great example of what it's like because
you can just scroll all the way around
up down everywhere and then you can use
this thing called smart track so if I
want to just track myself the entire
time throughout this clip I can do that
very easily in click smart track and now
it tracks me the entire time but there's
also something that it's my really
really favorite feature you basically it
can reshoot this clip so you just hold
the record button down and I can move
around and so basically in real time I'm
editing this video and I can then save
it share it out and then close it where
normal face
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you guys so much for watching I
hope that you enjoyed this video and I
look forward to making some more for you
so I'll see you guys on the Internet
bye